[Musique]
femmes la politique l'amour peut-être le
sexe et le reste c'est le thème de cette
édition avec que trois invités evelyne
dress bonjour bonjour vous êtes
évidemment comédienne metteur en scène
peintre aussi et écrivains ou écrivaine
écrivain vous préférez vous êtes un peu
de temps vieux vieux mode levier
je suis complètement démodée jeu a pas
du tout non alors
on commence en cause biot voix
séparaient les bains alors oui j'ai
mérité d'être un homme cela vous êtes
l'auteur est comme quand on le dit on
s'est passé aux mains ou pas on peut
faire les deux dans un livre qui
s'appelle cinq jours dans la vie d'une
de la vie d'une femme louis parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a toujours tendance à
penser à 24 heures de la vie d'une femme
on va on va raconter c'est très amusant
c'est au fond une femme qui se retrouve
seul le lot du réveillon qui se dit
plutôt que de rester seule balle dans la
tête avec la dan cole absolument ses
enfants je vais partir
non qui ont préféré aller réveillonner
avec des amis évidemment mais ce qu'il
faut peut-être dire d'entrée de jeu
c'est l'âge de mon héroïne oui à la 70e
elle a 70 ans mais c'est pas une mémé
c'est une femme on va en parler pendant
que justement d'iran ou voile s'est dit
je vais pas rester tout seul donc elle
part elle prend un billet d'avion pour
biarritz et elle va à berric dans le
plus bel hôtel qui est l'hôtel du palais
le prune suite à plus de 1000 euros la
jad hui encore bon allez hop on y va et
on va voir ce qui va se passer après
d'accord
la bénévole bonjour
ça va bien l'admettre de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et vous préfacé avec l'oréal qui le
livre de nicolas de condorcet alors
qu'ils étaient assez inconnu qui
conseille à sa fille et autres textes où
on voit alors c'est assez étonnant quoi
comment bad et des philosophes pouvait
être féministe havre on le sait il dit
si des femmes votre patron on exclut la
moitié de l'humanité c'est grave quand
même c'est pas d'aujourd'hui y aller et
pour ça mais très méconnu condorcet ce
qu'on a voulu montrer avec laurel makine
c'est cet ouvrage et on va parler avec
armel debray chopard bonjour bonjour
lettres de sciences politiques alors
vous êtes et vous avez été la première
femme agrégée de sciences politiques
absolument à ce que revient mais lorsque
vous avez dit aussi c'est que pendant
neuf ans il n'a pas eu des exactions
exactement vous
au site on a eu une ensuite depuis
maintenant maintenant cet acquis non
c'est acquis aux
jeux rappel le concours de deux
délégations de sources politiques ce
concours d'université
supérieur qui se passe après le doctorat
alors vous êtes vous venez pour un
magnifique livre qui s'appelle femmes et
et république est un livre collectif
préfacé par l'historienne michelle
perrot et dans laquelle voilà vous
raconter un peu l'histoire justement ben
on va voir ça quand est ce qu'on arrive
au vote des femmes relativement
tardivement d'ailleurs j'ai noté d'une
phrase de françois mitterrand que vous
publiez qu'il devait qu'il avait dit le
8 mars 1982 une bille mars c'était la
journée de la femme la france disait
françois mitterrand il faut le
reconnaître n'a pas été jusqu'à présent
à l'avant garde du progrès pour la
libération de la femme nous avons été le
dernier pays occidental je dis bien le
dernier pays occidental à accorder le
droit de vote aux femmes et puis
d'ajouter nous déplorons pas non plus la
directive européenne sur la légalité du
traitement professionnel c'est vrai que
c'est très étonnant
la france qui a été un peu en avance sur
la déclaration des droits de l'homme sur
un tout dans un certain nombre de plans
quêter regarde là justement de l'homme
mais sur le vote des femmes sur la
participation des femmes à la vie
politique on est très en retard
alors on est très en retard donc dans le
livre montre bien en plusieurs parties
la première partie c'est de la conquête
de ce droit de vote est donc
d'éligibilité puisque ça va ensemble la
deuxième partie c'est une fois acquis
non pas octroyer un acquis ce droit de
vote
comment les femmes vont exercer le
pouvoir et puis il ya une troisième
partie qui montrent la représentation de
la république comme par hasard cette
république qui est dirigé par des hommes
les représenter par une femme tu le vois
là rien donc c'est intéressant parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'imagés
la france est effectivement un pays très
très en retard ni compris par rapport à
l'europe pour le droit de vote puisque
beaucoup de pays européens l'ont obtenue
après la première guerre mondiale et est
ce qu'elle est la raison pour laquelle
nous en reste et si l'om alors il ya une
raison culturelle qui est le bon on a
quand même eu la loi salique alors qu'il
y avait
sur le
relayée par les écrits des philosophes
comme jean bodart au xvième siècle qui
disait mais si une femme arrivée au
pouvoir il ya plus de souveraineté ce
moment là qu'on met en avant le concept
de souveraineté c'est la gynéco cratie
l'horreur
enfin un peu de zemmour avant
l'assemblée
presque pire presque parce que plus ces
femmes se représenter non seulement
comme lui brille mais aussi les
assassinent leurs maris pour tendre le
pouvoir etc et l'exercice du pouvoir ne
va pas être une chose simple c'est parce
que ça ne suffit pas d'avoir le droit de
vote il faut encore non pas simplement
l'exercer les fameux l'on exercé très
bien dès le début il ya eu deux
abstentions mais elle n'arrive pas à
être élu et il ya une régression même du
nombre d'élus qui va se poursuivre dans
les premières années la preuve de classe
1re année de la vème république et
traités justement de la quatrième
république là il faut il faut raconter
quand même avant le droit de vote il ya
quand même eu des femmes ministres les
premières cessé avec léon blum alors
c'était pas des races les ministres ont
appelé ça à l'époque des
sous-secrétaires d'état
on en propulsant variés toujours des
secrétaires d'état et sous secrétaire
d'état il n'a plu c'était quoi les sous
secrétaires d'état c'était en dessous du
secrétaire
et ça veut simplement dire qu'il n'y
avait pas de femme qui était ministre de
plein exercice et sous la quatrième
république trois femmes seul moyen est
mini ce dont une seule sera une
féministe
- souche après germaine poisseux chapuis
et est là elle aura énormément de
difficultés
voilà toute façon elle était toujours
dans le socio éducatif oui les personnes
âgées les handicapés les jeunes
délinquants la face aux brûleurs il ya
joliot curie quand même qu'il y en a
trois il y en a qui en
plus de l'accord et irène joliot curie
voilà mais elle n'avait pas le elle
n'avait pas le droit de vote et il ya eu
tout un débat au cours de la troisième
république où on a refusé le droit de
vote enfin le sénat a refusé le droit de
vote aux femmes sous différents
prétextes elle allait semer la zizanie
elle allait importer le sexe dans
l'assemblée
tourner la tête des hommes qui ne
pourrait plus faire les lois comme si
elle était dans l'assemblée ne faisait
pas la mosquée c'est un argument qu'on
retrouve en
1945 quand l'école de la magistrature et
crée
le les magistrats disent mais si c'est
pas possible elles vont remporter le
sexe dans le pré 3 on va plus pouvoir
juger
sereinement et alors ils ont l'idée à ce
moment là ils se disent eh ben on l'aimé
on va faire quelque chose elles ne
pourront être que
magistrat dans le parc l2 peu poète
magistrats du siège évidemment ça n'a
pas pu passer c'était étaient hors la
loi oui on pourrait en faire une loi
pour dire en plus les arguments c'est
que
la femme elle est toujours un peu
fofolle les hystériques bref il ya une
nature de la femme et la nature de la
femme c'est ça qui expose au foyer et de
faire des enfants et cette mentalité
cette cette idée subsiste malgré tout
sous la troisième république sous la
ivème pardon y compris quand elles ont
droit de vote qui explique qu'elles sont
dans les commissions elles sont encore
dans les commissions sociale elle
s'occupe des semences souvent été le cas
20 longtemps était le cas je me mette
dans les mairies même dans les
aliments je suis juste ou le quatrième
aux brigands secrétaire d'état parce
qu'elle a été désignée humain même tupac
notre tactique était maire de
rambouillet n'ont atteint que les autres
si on était des plus des élues locales
très et puis avait alors moi je me suis
acheté petit rythme marie-madeleine dié
des sas et elle a la gnaque contournable
de la cinquième la fed de gaulle elle a
fait pour ça
qu'on pense depuis le début de la
quatrième république alors elle c'est
une caricature de ce que des hommes
attendent dit
non mais ne pas faire de de gaulle
disait on l'a on l'a mise là parce que
au moment avec elle on est tranquille
elle va pas faire déclare pas faire de
moi donc docile gentille faisant bien
son boulot bien appliqué exactement des
boulots
elle n'était pas dérangeante alors
autant mais c'est la seule au plus vite
avec avérés les loups des noms mais avec
de gaulle il ya eu une et parfois deux
hommes et un dea des postes le son genre
c'est lui ce choeur giscard alors le
changement c'est giscard on commence à
avoir deux trois parfois ça que
si l'on voit là
[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing qui veut
moderniser ça va un petit peu avec la
même idée que le vote à 18 ans et puis
françois mitterrand bien sûr là c'est un
énorme changement qui on arrive à jospin
épiler loi sur la parité la parité nous
qui n'est pas dans la loi d'ailleurs
mais le fait est que c'est la parité est
donc à partir de ce moment-là ça on peut
dire que ça décolle sa mère depuis quand
il y avait un gouvernement paritaire
depuis sûr que
ça m'intéresse a alors voulu mais vous
bien voir ce que ça veut dire
gouvernement paritaire parce que c'est
toujours pareil c'est comme égalité
hommes femmes dans les eaux autour
d'hommes que de femmes mais après il
faudrait regarder à quel niveau elles
sont si vous regardez le gouvernement le
dernier le castex je crois que même que
vous aviez 52% de femmes c'est à dire
mais plus de 22 de plus que la moitié 1
puisque paritaire mais vous n'aviez
qu'une seule femme à florence parly qui
est avait un ministère régalien
la défense donc donc il faut voir on
l'aimait si vous regardez la tour du
président de la république
ses conseillers c'est tous masculins oui
on sait plus ce que après c'est très
français ça le mystère régaliens mais
est ce que me sers du travail par
exemple c'est pas aussi important que mr
la justice mais est ce que je dis on est
très focalisés sur le régalien et il ya
peu des mini sacs sont aussi importants
et leveaux travail c'est elisabeth baume
qui est devenu premier ministre quand
même question il ya des deux ministères
qui sont tous les ministères sont
importants le travail d'un date du
cabinet du premier ou de la première
ministre c'est un ensemble c'est
transversal mais
un ministère régalien
applique aussi un ordre hiérarchique
dans le
et de prestige puisque c'est ça qui nous
intéresse le plus les hommes dans une
fac brebis ministre c'est vrai que sa
première première ministre elle dit
provient oui
nous allons discuter je me dis main
non mais c'est vrai que alors ça fait
tout un genre de pataquès facile c'est
marrant qu'on en fasse un débat quoique
ce soit un événement alors c'est vrai
qu'elle n'a qu'une jusqu à présent qu
edith cresson que ça s'est très bien
passé qu'elle était envoyée aux un peu
au casse-pipe 1
et celle qui a duré le moins longtemps
que les rémois non non non non je
n'avais pas une très bonne jour
soit
oui c'est ça c'est oui il faut avoir on
parle beaucoup de ça sur les femmes
c'est très intéressant ce que nous dit
parce que dans les campagnes électorales
il est possible que je sais pas réglé ça
c'est dd c'est peut-être des études un
peu machiste d'ailleurs qui dit ça mais
que les voix des femmes sont peut-être
un peu moins prégnante que ces désordres
à ses dépens des unes et des autres peu
importe et ça peut être si près c'est la
même chose pour un homme un homme est
très bien ne pas voir toi
une voix qui porte mais je crois que sur
une discrétion il n'y a pas que la voix
dia c'est à dire que il ya quand même eu
il ya elle a quand même dû subir la
trahison les coups bas de tout parti
socialiste euros et de pierre bérégovoy
notamment qui se disait pourquoi c'est
pas moi qui était nommé à sa place enfin
et en plus elle cite
les injures les injures pas nous
ça nous n'allait pas la voir vous
n'allez pas l'avoir avec elisabeth
bornes on ne serait plus politiquement
correct d'avoir ce type de réflexion
de réflexion mais l'idée de la voix
c'est aussi un des arguments qui a été
donné pour ne pas leur donner le droit
de vote et pour les empêcher même d'être
avocat ben oui parce qu'elle n'aurait
pas là le kof la première avocate en
1900 seulement c'est à dire que l épouse
déjà c'est très en avance
sous la révolution nota il ya très très
peu d'hommes qui la révolution de plein
de contradictions oui là
les femmes sont là olympe de gouges
théroigne de méricourt et d'autre mais
quand quand les montagnards et
robespierre arrive au pouvoir
malheureusement on leur ont leur propre
la parole et la terreur va aussi être
terrible pour pour les femmes et pour
revenir sur ce qu'on était en train de
dire à l'instant
en plus des arguments autour de la voix
il ya aussi des arguments qui sont les
femmes bah elles ont leurs règles elle
tombe enceinte les grossesses et ça ça
empêche de voter c'est vraiment un
argument qu'on va trouver rubin de
condorcet
qui dit bon alors si vous avez un rhume
et ou êtes malade vous les hommes
pourquoi on nous empresserons pas de
voter mais c'est vrai que cet argument
là de la grossesse des règles leur
revient vous est-ce que ce qui est paru
si cet argument politique qu'on a
beaucoup entendu et qui fait que la
gauche peut-être à hésiter que les
femmes de voter plutôt à droite tu es
plus conservatrice et quand vous dites
quand vous dites que robespierre au
moral c'est bien peut-être aussi cette
cette vidéo de la femme non alors
l'argument de ou alors comment marier
leurs maris
comme un communiqué
alors là c'est un argument qui a
effectivement été donnée l'argument
politique elles vont renverser la
république qui était plus laïque à tout
crin
et justement quand elles ont le droit de
vote au début de la 4è république
eh bien elle ne vote pratiquement comme
les hommes un tout petit peu plus à
droite c'est à dire un petit peu plus
mrp et effectivement on va avoir parmi
les députés qui sont élus les la
majorité des femmes élues et passer des
femmes communiste le feu n'en résoudrait
et on parlait de donc de première
ministre il ya quand même lorsque c'est
un plafond de verre est ce que c'est il
ya des circonstances politiques qui
peuvent les expliquer mais au fond
jusqu'à présent jamais aucune famille et
des femmes qui sont arrivés au deuxième
tour le pen ségolène royal à la
présidence de la république ça pas
vraiment marché est ce que est ce que
s'il ya ya est-ce qu'il ya encore un
petit plafond de verre qui fait que je
ne sais pas un ou 2 % ou 3 % d d d d
électeurs ne voterai jamais pour une
femme bien qu'on puisse pas le dire dans
les sondages personnes de se montrer de
ça mais est ce que ça pourrait exister
ça a changé et c'est là que ce qu'a dit
edith cresson récemment que ya un gap
entre l'opinion va vous y croyez à ça
oui et là
l'opinion publique qui étaient
majoritairement même encore du temps de
mitterrand défavorable à une femme
présidente de la république est
maintenant majoritairement favorable ou
pas n'y voit pas n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient
alors la cinquième république puisque
nous sommes dans la came république elle
s'est construite d'une façon qui est pas
simplement
masculine mais qui est viril avec le
général de gaulle militaire qui
pensaient que la femme devait rester au
foyer ce qu'on appelle l'homme
providentiel
dans ciel l'homme sans
nom je pense que gaia il ya un décalage
entre ce que maintenant accepterait par
l'endettement des jeunes générations oui
absolument suis très optimiste sur la
façon générale je me demandais si par
exemple dans une période compliquée
comme celle qu'on vous vie avec une
guerre etc il n'y a pas ou petite france
je ne dis pas mais souvent les élections
ça se joue à deux ou trois pour cent
vingt ans macron voilà deux des
événements nucléaires
ça c'est un fait nathalie justement
alors quand on prend l c'est très
intéressant parce que ce que je vous
montre mais l'orage passé au fond d'un
longue conquête qu'il a fallu un pour
arriver à la situation d'aujourd'hui et
pourtant des dardenne révolution ou ddd
condorcet il ya dès hier des philosophes
qu'il dise on peut pas les repas pas
laisser aller car la moitié de
l'humanité oui c'est très beau
livre extraordinaire auquel on sait bien
sûr appuyé de d'elisabeth badinter qui
s'appelle parole d'homme qui a recherché
le nom de révolutionnaire et d'hommes
qui prennent la parole pour les droits
des femmes pendant la révolution et elle
écrit qu on les compte sur les doigts
d'une main donc il faut quand même
savoir que même chez les philosophes des
lumières
pourtant ouvert vers l'idée d'abord de
tolérance et d'égalité
qui lutte contre
les discriminations faites aux noirs aux
juifs aux protestants même chez eux
l'idée de donner des droits de vote aux
femmes est une idée complètement folle
et même roues sont par exemple sont si
on va regarder ce qui a écrit rosso
c'est complètement fou parce que pour
lui pour rousseau la flamme célèbre jeu
de séduction dont armel parler elle doit
rester elle doit rester à la maison donc
en réalité il ya très très peu de
philosophes des lumières qui vont prôner
ce droit de vote pour les femmes et
condorcet d'exception
extrêmement engagé le tue quand je serai
très engagé alors ce qu'on a voulu me
stresse quand on lui ça sert on est
fasciné parce qu'on retrouve des
arguments qu'on pourrait retrouver
aujourd'hui quoi enfin de la part des
féministes à va il est très très très
moderne allant des faits d'une partie
des féministes ans je le dis devant tout
parce qu'il est universel il tombera
parce que
c'est magnifique c'est condorcet parce
que il est il est subtil et fin il est
dans la nuance d'ailleurs c'était pour
ça qu'il est moins connu que d'autres
philosophes comme voltaire ou comme
d'autres 1
c'est un homme extrêmement nuancé et
c'est donc on a dans cet ouvrage qu'on a
on a préfacé avec laurel maquille on a
on a montré à travers les textes de
condorcet on en a retrouvé de theix
complètement inédit dans lesquels nos
conduites addictives aura qu'on sait
c'est que ça j'ai des textes qu'on
connaissait pas détection connaissez pas
un pur en 1790 et un texte qui s'appelle
d'une excuse moi j'ai un trou de mémoire
sur le dit tout en étant ceux décrits
que de le lire et de le relier voilà sur
l'admission des femmes au droit de cité
où il montre que l'on ne peut pas
exclure la moitié de moitié de la
population aux droits de vote et on
arrive à avoir une argumentation
extrêmement
forte puissante il a démonté tous les
arguments dont on vient de parler pour
dire voilà pourquoi il n'y a aucune
raison d'exclure les femmes du droit de
vote et pourquoi pas une femme qui
préside un tribunal une armée dont on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est très très
précurseur et l'instruction alors parce
qu'il ya aussi l eia que fayet et
toujours cette idée que je te parle à
peine que les que les femmes c'est des
études à deux vous disiez mon première
femme avocate au début du siècle bébé
pendant très longtemps fin même passer
le bac c'était c'était un drame absolu
direct trouvera pas marie faire des
études c'était et et voilà c'est très
récent il faut se baser bien clé c'est
ça c'est fou parce que condorcet dit
voilà il faut une pour avoir la
citoyenneté ça marche avec la structure
vraiment ensemble c'est dialectique il
faut il faut les deux pour les femmes
qui prône une instruction publique
gratuite laïque pour les garçons et pour
les filles et il va encore plus loin que
ce qui sera fait par jules ferry un
siècle plus tard c'est qu'il va dire
voilà les filles et garçons doivent
aller à l'école ensemble c'est
extraordinaire même attendre les années
1970 pourra consister à vivre ensemble
on mélangeait pas jeter plus de sa
pratique pas ce qu'on allait voir comme
ça la sortie d'école des
garçons et ont prié dans
les courbes
de cuisine chez moi même pour les
mathématiques il paraît que ça l'aurait
le registre n'aurait pas supporté
mais et de l'année on a toujours ce
cette différence est de dire que en gros
les les filles sont meilleures que les
garçons dans le secondaire mais quand on
passe aux grandes écoles il ya cette
sorte de pression sociale qui fixe et
plus les garçons ils vont notamment dans
les sciences y ait des études très
remarquable de suivre il ya plus de
garçons ils voient plus technique que de
filles alizé backboard étant une
exception puisque les prix le technicien
mais faille il a eu peu au départ quand
le politique j'ai peu près 5 6 fissures
ven tes lèvres alors que alors que dans
les études elles sont meilleures nous
n'avons nous avons je dirais 70% de
financements ballon et enfin endroits
humides et non médecine aux fins de
l'étude montrent que à l'université les
filles sont meilleures que les garçons
elles redoublent mois etc etc mais après
on a une question carla qui promène
question de culture c'est à dire qu'elle
ne s'oriente pas vers les les carrières
et les études scientifiques et donc
hélas c'est là qu'on verra les deux
questions mais les deux questions en
amont de l'école commencer par là soir
là par la maison ont commencé par le
rose et le bleu les jouets pour les
garçons n'est joué pour les filles pas
faire comme à fait le
supermarché d'à côté il ya quelques
années qui a voulu être très féministe
donc il a dit les blés les camions ça
peut être aussi bien pour les pour les
petites filles que pour les garçons et
donc il y avait des camions rose pour
les faits liés
à la bible
votre lit s'appelle femmes et république
donc c'est très français c'est évident
cela c'est la fronde est ce que la
situation des femmes s'est mieux passé
ailleurs où il n'y avait pas eu ces mots
de république
et
la démocratie
je pense aux aux pays anglo saxons
notamment fait ou pas forcément des
républiques du co2 démocratie santé
démocratie oui
à 6 mai mais que mais la république au
fond est-ce qu'elle a été un
encouragement pour les femmes ou
peut-être un frein il faut savoir de
quelle heure puis si on parle de
l'europe de quelle république on parle
si on regarde le royaume uni mais si on
parle de la république française au
royaume-uni finalement on a eu des
femmes premier ministre mis en avant
nous et regarder les pays du nord aussi
et là je crois qu'il ya une culture oui
qui vient de la religion et on sait que
dans les pays protestants qui tombait
hier plus ouvert qui ont été plus ouvert
par exemple au divorce le droit de
divorcer on sait que les femmes
acceptent plus facilement à des
fonctions publiques mais auparavant
elles ont déjà eu plus de droit souligne
d'ailleurs quand on a regardé quand
continue la numérisation de l'homme bob
première du premier ministre il ya eu
des cartes qui a été fait aux voix oui
dans les pays nordiques et puis que dès
qu'on arrive au pays d'atteindre en gros
c'est un peu ça lol exactement pays
catholique en effet tony curtis
catholique il n'y a pas de femmes
casuistique alors que vous avez des
pasteurs reut
il joue les rappeurs de condorcet de la
religion
un autre exemple quand même c'est
intéressant c'est qu'elle la turquie qui
donne le droit de vote aux femmes avant
nous en 1934
atatürk enjoint les femmes à retirer
leur foulard islamique
et puis bon malheureusement connaît la
suite courir doan arrive au pouvoir et
les enfants seraient
et
du mexique aussi qui
oui mais leur condorcet et la religion
va écouter ses c'est vrai que la
question des femmes elle est toujours
lié à la question d'or à la question
donc de la religion évidemment et
condorcet va faire partie avec les
encyclopédistes c'est le dernier des
encyclopédistes ils sont de près 150
auteurs et beaucoup sont croyants on à
diderot qui athée mais là la plupart
quand même sont croyants et tous vont
lutter non pas contre la religion mais
contre le pouvoir de l'église contre les
excès de l'église contre le fanatisme de
l'église et condorcet va s'inscrire dans
ce
droit fil de contestation de
l'obscurantisme religieux
la politique ça vous
intéresse
oui forcément
difficile de s que vous montriez plus
pour une femme pas où vous est égal mais
je vais me faire haïr je préfère un
homme à
huy penser que c'est plus un masculin la
faute aux politiques et cd vous avez
gold and mr et vous avez
merkel en allemagne mais elles sont à
l'achat 1 7e oui elles ne sont pas très
féminine regardez ce qui se passe ce
soir et
je suis choisi un président de la cub
sur le genre
devraient se foutent complètement de sa
voix ses herbes folles
non il faut avoir une autorité naturelle
et ça c'est pas féminin ou masculin
c'est une personne et voilà mais je
pense qu'il faut quand même donc
quelqu'un qui a une voix et une présence
de quelques gros
et aimé par exemple ce n'est pas besoin
de micro jeux d'essai c'est une question
de stature je pense qu'il faut avoir les
tos voilà le costume cravate
c'est très traditionaliste c'est très
très
jeune ferrailleur
au contraire je pense qu'il faut j'ai lu
un livre qui m'a beaucoup plu qui
s'appelle le voyant détente d'abel
content oui qui raconte l'histoire d'un
homme qui écrit un texte absolument
magnifique sur un poète américain est il
écrit ce livre il se trouve que ce poète
américain et noir mais qu'il est
tellement passionné de l'art de cet
auteur qu'il omet de dire qu'il est noir
ah oui et donc où seul mobile révéler
tous les médias s'en prennent à lui sa
part d'un truc pas avoir d mais ce qui
l'intéressait c'était l'oeuvre et moi je
crois que qu'ils s'agissent de noir ou
de blanc ou danger de femmes tout à fond
quand je lis un livre je me fiche de
savoir que l'auteur est un homme une
femme ça ne m'intéresse pas il
m'intéresse c'est l'oeuvre des jeunes
que je crois qu'il faut donc une fois
qu'on sera là c'est que pour l'ol
non pas parce que votre test nous dise
un livre de faim ou six films de fin
c'est ça aussi horrible c'est assez pour
faire une femme
qui parlait des vrais je parle en tant
que réalisatrice tant que réalisatrice
ou pas d'amour sans minutes
qui dénonçait ce qu'on dénonce
aujourd'hui
le mythe ou avant mitumba la météo avait
mis tous et à l'époque évidemment tout
le monde m'est tombé dessus c'était
quelque chose qu'on n'avait pas le droit
de dire de dénoncer et voilà et et j'ai
été soupçonné de tout
toutes les rumeurs et tous enfin j'ai
été très gâtés et un jour j'en ferai un
livre vous après ce que traiter de
sorcière ce qui pourrait intéresser à
main levée
mais
venons en à ce roman c'est combientième
sa 10e 12e 1 oui cinq jours de la vie
d'une femme devient disque aussi
l'édition de livres alors vous aborder
un problème très
passionnant et très sulfureux russe et
celui de fond de la sexualité à à 70 en
quoi ses 70 ans il ya encore comme ça
des des idées reçues qu'une femmes après
la ménopause
ça va avec faire la cuisine
et donc elle n'a plus de vie sexuelle
elle n'est plus bon à rien
or donc dans le livre est dans la vie je
veux justement défendre l'idée qu'une
femme peut faire l'amour jusqu'au bout
et il faut que dans la mortalité des
femmes ça change parce qu'on leur a
tellement inculquer que c'était fini
pour elle et qu'elle n'avait plus qu'à
s'occuper des petits enfants qu'elle ne
s'autorise pas le le droit de séduire et
d'avoir encore une jouissance et
récemment je déjeunais avec une amie qui
me disait tu vois maintenant que je suis
installé dans mon petit studio parce
qu'elle s'est séparée dont elle a moins
de moyens et elle est dans un petit
studio et elle adore
son endroit et elle me dit mais
maintenant tu vois je me sentirai prête
à rentrer à rencontrer quelqu'un je lui
dis ah bon mais tu as quel âge indique
80 ans ma mais tu crois que tu serais
capable de faire l'amour mais bien sûr
cela dit ça ne dépend que de l'autre
voilà et donc les hommes ont le droit de
faire l'amour jusqu'au bout jusqu'à 80
et 90 quand ils peuvent oui certes mais
oui c'est plutôt les mecs déguisés plus
difficile
à avoir des désirs ses de lubrifier
jusqu'au bout c'est peut-être pour ça
donc dans votre dans votre roman
l'héroïne donc on l'a dit qu'il parle
comme ça parce qu'elle est tout seul
pour le réveillon de noël par donc à
l'hôtel du palais à biarritz peuvent pas
forcément dans l'idée de trouver
quelqu'un au
départ d'ailleurs pour une nuit oui
simplement c'est pas dans son état
d'esprit de rendre ces îles vierges pas
le seul donc elle se faire beau pour
dîner avec 20 alors qu'elle n'a pas
l'habitude d'en boire et
elle s'offre oui là là une chance suite
le prix est parce qu'elle n'a pas
l'intention d'être la plus riche du
cimetière donc voilà elle est partie
comme ça sur un coup de tête pour ne pas
rester chez elle toute seule le soir du
réveillon
quand elle voit les prix du du de la
carte aussi se dit ça va me coûter cher
mais aux freins
et donc l afld a les moyens de rester
plus de deux nuits et puis on les
rencontre la vie beach d'attirance pour
un garçon assez jeune plus jeune qu'elle
si julien puis j'allais un peu jeune
alors et c'est peut-être ce que disait
la crise et aux faux c'est plus dur de
80 ans pour les pour les mecs
de femmes est ce que c'est pour ça que
nos vins est ce que
je dis comme ça leur arrive et s'en
vante facilement oui est ce que c'est
pour ça alors
qu'à partir de 70 ans au fond une femme
qui veut avoir une vie sexuelle elle a
plutôt tendance à rechercher des
partenaires plus jeunes qu'elles ben
c'est à dire pardon messieurs
mais à 70 ans généralement les hommes se
sont laissé aller son de son du ventre
et sombre voilà et donc quand on a 70
ans qui ont des souvenirs
on a envie de chair fraîche mais aussi
donc on va pas de pousser la petite
[Rires]
l'autre dit le petit couple offrir
un peu de gens semblent mis un peu
pardon d'autobiographie dans le roman
évidemment je parle de jeune talent et
aussi avec total ça vous est arrivé ça
m'est arrivé justement après vous
réalisez pas d'amour sans un bourg mon
film subversif pour l'ecoop l'époque
et
où la france entière du du métier du
cinéma m'était tombé dessus parce qu'en
plus non seulement je disais des choses
dont on ne parlait pas mais j'étais
auteurs réalisateurs producteurs
je jouais le rôle principal du film ça
c'était absolument insupportable oui et
alors que le film était sélectionné pour
les golden globes à los angeles et qu'
elle là bas j'étais invité par toutes
les ligues de femmes et on disait elle
écrit elle produit elle joue elle
réalise s'appelle evelyne dress alors
ici elle écrit 1 elle joue elle réalise
elle balaye palplanches et pendant
qu'elle y le faire donc j'ai été aussi
obligé de distribuer mon film qu'il y a
c'est quoi c'est une mise ni du nu et
métiers oui bien sûr mais c'est la même
que dont vous avez parlé
mais elle est très ancrée est
bon il ya tellement c'est un sujet qui
devient tellement large tellement vaste
qui me semble qu'une heure ne suffit pas
pour en parler et donc j'ai distribué
donc mon film qui a fait un bon score
meilleur que certains films à la cave et
puis quand il passe avec des livres je
vais plus mignon et demie 7 millions
129,80 téléspectateurs 1 face au foot
sur tf1 psg guingamp match de la ligue
dont un énorme succès et voilà bon et
donc on vous en a voulu un peu pour moi
oui oui
jusqu'à présent je n'ai pas réussi à
faire le deuxième film parce que tout de
suite après c'était absolument
impossible j'ai eu la chance de
découvrir que j'étais capable de de
peindre d'abord il y eut ensuite décrire
et donc voilà je me suis réparé avec
l'écriture parce que ce que vous dites
sur l'âge alors la sexualité c'est une
chose mais lâche des comédiennes c'est
aussi un problème tout à fait je suis
une comédienne vieillissante alors quand
on me propose un rôle c'est un rôle de
grand mère est-ce qu'en plus j'ai le
culot de laisser mes cheveux blancs et
catherine deneuve ne laisserait pas ses
cheveux blancs elle sait très bien que
ça limiterait dans les rôles
nathalie baye iliad rennes 2 dark
nathalie baye c'est un peu d exception
c'est à dire que c'est des femmes
la transition que vous dites mais lipkow
des rouges qui au début oui mais après
les appels huppert
elle est long tous les rôles les
meilleurs rôles en ce qui me concerne on
propose des grands mères alors je dis
que travers
et qu'elle est quel est l'âge de mon
fils 40 ans ah oui mais je suis désolé
parce que moi à 40 ans je ne vais pas
des fils jean fait d amour
c si je viens jouer le grand mère ce
qu'elle se taclent le copain de son fils
[Rires]
ça manque d'imagination encore clair que
dont je m'habille en prada
et la fille
se fait ça mais les cheveux blancs pour
avoir justement une certaine autorité et
tout ça je pourrais jouer des wonder
woman à papa des grands-mères la maison
ça c'est oui à quoi un manque
d'imagination ou font des réalisateurs
de cinéma
celeron comme de chalandise hausse et
d'une grand mère c'est tout voilà il
faudrait que j'adapte moment et
ça le faisait dans la vie d'une femme ça
ferait un très bon film on va pas
raconter tout le roman mais il ya il ya
deux hommes portant dans dans ce roman
ce jeune dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
avec lequel l'héroïne à fait
satisfaisant we
fall pérou l'équateur
le corps touchée par un masseur je m'en
sors oui voilà donc je racontais ça dans
un autre de mes romans pas d'amour sans
amour donc justement
elle mon héroïne qui était abstinente
depuis plusieurs années avait tout d'un
coup une pulsion un désir d'être touchés
et donc elle prend rendez vous chez une
masseuse et qui
l'invitent à se mettre sur la table de
massage et il est bon alors qu'est ce
qui ne va pas et ben voila j'ai pas fait
l'amour depuis trois ans alors qu'on met
ma main je vais pas vous faire un
massage érotique non madame c'est pas
trés dont il s'agit vous savez je suis
comme un enfant un bébé qui a besoin que
sa maman le touche voilà c'est ça le
truc c'est qu'on a besoin du toucher on
peut se passer de pénétration mais on ne
peut pas se passer du regard de l'autre
et du toucher de la gare res voilà c'est
ça qui fait du bien alors il y avait vu
par cette zone donc il ya ce jeune homme
puis un autre à l'ag un peu plus très
prévenants très amicale d'un montant
consolation raconte pas la fin du livre
naturellement
est ce qu'il ya au fond 1
est ce qu'un type d'homme qui
s'intéresse aux femmes âgées
à la bonne question oui des jeunes
hommes qui s'intéressent à des femmes
mûres pas plus tard qu'hier je me suis
fais draguer
en arrosant mes plans sur le boulevard
et tout à coup est arrivé une jeune
femme qui était la compagne qui est
qu'est ce que tu veux tu veux tu veux
encore qu'est ce que tu veux mais j'ai
eu peur tout d'un coup
ça me ça m'amuse et heureusement parce
que je lui ai rien répondu j'ai continué
à lui sourire
mais donc oui elle était inquiète de mes
cheveux bleus jeu blanc oui comme quoi
les femmes sont des choses
là bas vous êtes aussi intéressés alors
vous avez fait un livre dessus puis il
ya un chapitre drones dans ce livre ou à
la première dame
c'est intéressant ça parce qu'il ya pas
de statut
mais c'est un rôle qui compte quand même
tout dépend de la personne de dépôt de
la personne et des droits de la personne
le meilleur exemple c'est bernadette
chirac premier mandat de chirac effacée
elle ya quoi à coacher j'existe pas tout
n'a que pour aux clauses de sa fille qui
se gère la communication de de jacques
chirac et puis ben chirac au deuxième
mandat il a ainsi un petit problème de
santé et elle reprend les choses en main
et là elle va vraiment les reprendre en
main et ça a été favorisée par le fait
qu'elle s'est occupée des pièces jaunes
et là elle a acquis une popularité qui
lui a permis ensuite
deux allemandes et de 2,2 de s'imposer
alors ensuite ça dépend évidemment de
des personnalités on voit que
actuellement brigitte macron alain rôle
important voilà emmanuel c'est parce
qu'il ferait sens
et puis on voit hélas aussi une heure
une différence d'âge
c'est bien dans le bon sens
j'adore j'adore ce couple excusez moi
mais franchement le fait que et emmanuel
macron soit amoureux et alors évidemment
il a été traité de
alors que scénique c'est magnifique
c'est déjà un point positif mais c'est
vrai mais on a en a sept cet exemple là
et c'est ce qui est très frappant c'est
à dire que pour beaucoup de gens c'était
impossible oui ça n'existe pouvait pas
exister de relation entre un homme meurt
et donc ou alors il ya sa cacher quelque
chose enfin saisi pouvait pas imaginer
que voilà qu'ils ont hier on est
forcément un gigolo ou un homosexuel
signer ton s'il tombe amoureux d'une
femme plus âgée que lui ce que je dis
toujours c'est que à l'horizontale on se
ressemble tous quel que soit l'âge et ce
qui est extraordinaire je vais vécu
plusieurs fois avec des copines à moi
dont je sais qu'elles ont une grosse
cicatrice qui barre le le milieu du
ventre tout ça mais quand un homme est
amoureux il ne voit pas la cicatrice
voir rim il va pas larini rien mon
cerveau mais oui
mais c'est surtout la personne qui est
importante c'est bah voilà et et aussi
je pourrais je sais pas si j'ai le temps
mais
lorsque j'étais comédienne je tournais
dans une propriété d'un loueur de
chevaux et de carros etc et c'est sa
femme qui me maquillais alors il ya une
grande proximité avec la maquilleuse
quand on est comédienne et
je la trouvais très moche bon mais en
tout cas son mari rentré toutes les cinq
minutes dans la cuisine où elle me
maquillais et ma chérie tu apache au
tabac froid tu veux un petit café de
mémoire qui avait déjà des difficultés
dans menix histoire de couple je devais
admirative jeudi quand même
extraordinaire ton mec alors elle dit
oui
j'ai commencé la rencontre et
je faisais mon service militaire quand
j'ai tué israélien non non pas du tout
j'étais un garçon âgé gabon mais elle
lui c'était jean errol flynn à la petite
moustache et où le mec vie rien et tout
jésus mais il est tombé amoureux d'un
garçon et maintenant il est avec une
fille alors md mais alors il est
amoureux d'une personne pas d'un sexe
c'est ça ça va parler de l'histoire
c'est pâques ont raconté que j'ai bâti
et des web et c'était je crois que c'est
des oeuvres de boulle qui avait pris des
cours d'élocution avec escompte de la
commune i française et un jour il va
voir elle va le voir jouer à la comédie
française et qu'elle a failli valls à
lui ai fait une liste beatty et qu à
madame claude como va t'elle et les
communes elle fait son service militaire
[Rires]
quel que soit le sexe peut importe c'est
la personne qui compte et c'est ça qui
est beau première dame il y en a qui
n'en a pas ou presque c'est françois
hollande
valérie trierweiler n'a pas compris ce
qu'était la rentrée elle cachait pas les
casaques aux épaules et cas parce que le
président de la république en france
c'était selon une règle non écrite ça
devait être un homme marié
pas divorcer et pas marié avec une
divorcée ce qui était le cas ce que tu
as posé de problème pour raymond
poincaré parce qu'ils étaient mal était
pas divorcer mais il était marié à une
divorcée et ça pose un problème et bâle
après sa naissance est mis à coeur joie
ce lundi sous la vème je suis enfin en
on a reproché âge ça pour dell passe
d'avoir divorcé né à caen c'était un
argument c'est vrai que ni mitterrand ni
giscard qui pourtant ouvre peut-être eu
des aventures sait-on jamais divorcé
pour être non plus ouais c'est comme
en 2000 en 2007 quand il ya eu la main
la primaire socialiste fabius étaient
sur les rangs et il songer à se remarier
pour lui parce que tu as et n'a donc
véritablement la coupure c'est sarkozy
non tu as et 2007 oui sarkozy de sarkozy
pendant tellement sarkozy à ségolène
royal oui on sait c'est que le royal oui
non seulement une femme au second tour
mais n'aime pas divorcer n'étaient pas
mariés n'étaient pas mariés et
leurs quatre enfants il ya la rupture
avec françois hollande pendant la
campagne électorale ce qui va ajouter un
peu de difficulté de cette course très
bon complément et puis ensuite on voit
arriver
un divorce et sarkozy et en plus ils
divorcent rodgers se remarie dans mary à
l'elysée et puis bon l'évolution en
france nous on arrive à françois
hollande qui introduit sa maîtresse une
première dame et qui reste d'ailleurs
pas longtemps et françois hollande
elle se met pas du tout en avant la
belle veut pas se mettre au vélo et
pièces à laisser les quolibets c'est un
peu une modernisation venons de
oui mais là
on est à peu revenues en arrière
chacun fait comme il
effectivement ça compte pas du tout
c'est qu'on est dans un couple oui c'est
pas sorcier place oui mais pour moi
c'est un couple hyper traditionnel alors
la différence la différence c'est qu'eux
et là aussi la
la femme du président qu'on a appelé
avec sarkozy la première dame en
allusion à la first lady puis alors
qu'il
n'y a pas de bug en a pas aux états unis
non plus un gablé iliad il ya des
quelques quelques quelques règles et
donc elle devait être discrète il ya des
présidents de la république comme
fallières qui imposait à leurs femmes de
marché
de 10 pas derrière et là on voit que
physiquement
ils von de gaulle est pas monté sur la
tribune avec avec le général elle s'est
même perdu dans la foule au canada
puisque
et puis un bon là les gardes du corps la
baltique oui ben les gardes du corps
l'avaient perdue yvonne îlot à nous et
elle est donc on voit maintenant ça a
commencé avec sarkozy mais emmanuel
macron dans des cérémonies officielles
tenant la main de l'homme de lettres à
noah n'ont
jamais
réellement à non non non non non non non
et plis celles qui ont écrit leur
mémoire après coup un sauf bernadette
chirac qui avait fait des interviews
se sont bien gardés de
transgresser leur droit de réserve
donc non on dit discrétion et brigitte
mâcon c'est là que je dis que c'est
traditionnel est là quand même elle est
très importante et on le sait mais elle
s'efforce de ne pas se mettre en avant
ils ont tellement quand on lui pose une
question il répond avec pertinence et
brièveté d'ailleurs n'ont pas de
position politique voilà mais elle
assume parfaitement cette cette réserve
qui est le lot d'un écrit une fois de
plus de la femme du président lé pa lé
palais pas élu c'est une citoyenne comme
les autres mais qui en plus à des
contraintes qui sont pas celles de vous
et moi
nathalie france à ce que vous dites tout
est là vous parlez d'olympe de gouges a
fallu de deux femmes qui sont donc le
jouer des rôles très importants
est ce que on n'a pas
manqué une étape enfin est-ce qu'on ne
pas été justement pourquoi il a fallu
attendre 45 quand même pour le vote des
femmes je reviens quand même cette
question mais étonnante et
il ya eu il y avait quoi il y avait
quand même un machisme ambiant
même si révolutionnaire même cd c'est
très étonnant parce que
notamment ces femmes qui qui qui portent
des combats absolument majeur puis après
il ya quand même aussi napoléon qui
arrivent au pouvoir et on peut pas dire
que ce soit
on ait eu et
et en effet alors après ça suppose un
peu moins bien ces sujets là sur la
partie troisième république mais les
choses se font extrêmement lentement il
faut il faudra il faudra du temps et je
comment l'expliquez comment expliquer la
7,6 de marcheurs république reprend
exactement la suite de dudus pourtant
permet donc à 1848 on instaure le
suffrage universel ce qu'on lisait
encore dans nos livres d'histoire mais
seulement pour les hommes alors les fans
ne comprennent pas il ya déjà quelques
des groupes de femmes qui réclament
leur donnera le droit privé elle ne
voulait pas avec les femmes elle se
disait que les femmes justement ce
n'était pas fait pour faire de la
politique elle aurait été très bien
avez-vous
est non alors en 1848 les hommes dans
leur euphorie il faut un décret pour le
scrutin
que tous les français ont le droit de
vote et il ya une condition d'âge bon
alors les femmes se disent enfin le
masculin l'emporté sur les féminines sur
le féminin dans tous les français il ya
les françaises alala problème est alors
ils disent ah mais oui
effectivement vous êtes compris dans
tous les français mais vous avez
remarqué qu'à une condition d'âge et la
condition d'âge c'était qu'il fallait
être en âge viril
et la troisième république en ces débuts
va reprendre textuellement
textuellement ceux de ce décret et pis
les femmes densifie curieux ne sont
toujours pas river d'un jeu viril
la première guerre mondiale quand même
qu'il joue un rôle important les guerres
c'est sous ces centièmes exactement le
comportement des femmes pendant la
première guerre mondiale était
absolument admirable pendant la deuxième
aussi alors ça peut-être entraîner sa
dans la résistance et ça c'est vrai
qu'elle est elle son ouïe
existence et même si ça va
ça n'a pas suffit
à montrer la jouer mais surtout
joué au royaume uni et dans d'autres
pays européens on les a en quelque sorte
remercier mais au retour de la guerre
est bien ça a été le retour des hommes
et il ya eu il ont eu un petit peu
dépression les hommes parce que les
femmes avaient un peu les choses seuls
les choses en main et donc ça le ferait
on a d'abord commencé à faire des
monuments aux morts partout pour bien
montrer que c'est les élisant et que la
bête est notre loi et où ils ont repris
leur place exactement
comme avant mais ils ont renvoyé la
femme sans cela c'est sur nous et on
voit on voit le même genre de choses
rond dans des pays d'afrique après
d'après des révolutions par exemple
au rwanda qui finalement les femmes
aussi ont réclamé après le génocide
après la guerre
elles avaient leur place on leur a donné
textuellement sur le plan politique
elles ont beaucoup plus d'élus que 50%
mais on les a fait des hommes les ont
fait rentrer peut-être encore plus
durement à la maison parce que il y
avait une perte de pouvoir de leur part
donc là on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
un problème c'est pas simplement une
étourderie de la part des hommes ou un
phénomène culturel qui se prolonge sur
ton rôle veille ya quand même une
résistance et cette résistance et les
sommes des hommes c'est vraiment la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui va marquer
une rupture encore que comme vous dites
sous la quatrième république peut-être
aussi parce que c'est sûr d'aider des
régimes
ces parlementaires ou les parties où
beaucoup de pouvoir et les partis sont
plutôt au mas des hommes
et des représentations curé plus
délicieusement et on s'arrangeait pour
les mettre à l'abri les communistes wii
bleue dans une position où ils n'étaient
pas éligibles et lucie aubrac par
exemple a été mise dans une une position
non éligible par waldeck rochet qui
trouvait que cette femme prenait un
petit peu trop d'ailleurs apparaître le
s'exprimer sur un public voilà merci
infiniment je l'appelle se livrent à la
documentation française dont keith aulie
collectif avec une préface de michel
perron femmes et république
nathalie wolf donc nicolas de condorcet
conseil à sa fille et autres textes et
folio oui ça s'appelle conseil à sa
fille parce qu'il écrit absolue grandir
tout à l'heure si je suis encore monter
seconde il écrit il et il est le
condamné à mort par robespierre ils sont
fusillés en fuite il se cache et une
femme qui va le madame verner quelques
achats à paris finalement il est arrêté
et il sait qui va il sait qu'il va
mourir et il écrit un très très beau
texte c'est un film absolument
magnifique ce conseil à sa fille où il
lui dit au fond pour être heureuse il
lui donne tout un ensemble de conseils
extrêmement moderne et émouvant pour
être heureuse alors déjà c'est pas le
bonheur dans le mariage donc là aussi
c'est extrêmement précurseur et en plus
pour l'époque il lui dit et l'estiment
de toi et trouver un travail que tu
aimes et c'est pour ça que le le recueil
s'intitule conseil à sa fille donc c'est
vraiment un combat qu'il a mené sur le
plan politique et qui s'adresse à toutes
les femmes et cet ouvrage se termine sur
ce texte très intime il s'adresse à une
femme sa fille et le livre à son droit
pourrait être le sous titre de cinq
jours de la vie d'une femme
evelyne dress audition glyphes j'espère
que vous allez avoir le la possibilité
de l'adapter au cinéma ou au théâtre de
sa frappe
toutes les critiques ont dit que ça
ferait un très bon film ah ouais je suis
d'accord et en pis je pourrais jouer le
rôle
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui manque un peu d'argent et
encore ça ne coûte pas très cher en plus
en plus où ils pourraient par la suite à
1000 euros la nuit
après oui il serait très très heureux
que je vienne
selon bercy merci beaucoup merci à tous
les trois et a très vite pas pour une
nouvelle émission de dix vivront
[Musique]
on